what you say about in the documentary
and in the book you're a hundred percent
right it was great for Tommy this tape
because he's a rock star he's the
drummer in Motley Crew for me it really
did undermine your career it did it did
sort of change the the perception of who
Pamela Anderson was yeah I guess I mean
it wasn't a a positive thing it was it
definitely took its took its toll on the
relationship it took its toll on
um my career and people are still
capitalizing off that that was was the
shocking part I remember seeing this ham
and Tommy thing on Hulu or some
advertisement for it and I thought what
the hell is this no one called me no one
else
doing it no oh no nothing to do with me
I saw you say that in the Netflix
special that you won't look at it and I
don't blame you I wouldn't look at it
either do you ever try to contact uh I
know Seth Rogen was one of the producers
he's a a very reasonable guy did you
ever say so
yeah I tried to reach out now I felt
like I just felt kind of run over with
that one I think
um I don't think they really
portrayed Tommy or I positively I don't
know I mean I only heard that it was a
very shallow kind of representation of
of us but you know of that time but I
don't know why I mean I wish they would
have
called
well had they called maybe you could
have said look I'm not comfortable with
this or maybe you could have even said
hey well maybe we can collaborate on my
life story yeah maybe I mean I don't
think I probably would have been
involved because especially about that
subject matter I just why why bring it
up again and you know bringing it up
again but I just felt that's why you
know Brandon's the one who produced the
film the documentary he was like Mom you
just need to tell your story because I
just want to make sure that you get to
tell your story you know like write this
book and and then the documentary I just
said here I haven't killed anybody
here's the keys to my archives and you
can read my Diaries everything I said
let's just let it all out